well everybody was going on welcome to
another Python tutorial video in the
last video we covered the try except
else statement where the else statement
only runs if the exception is not
triggered but what if we always want to
run some code in the trying to accept
statement but we want that code to be
somewhat contingent on the outcome of
the try next up statement for this we
use try accept finally so here's a quick
example of a try accept finally so we'll
say try x equals x plus 3 so that's
gonna obviously fail and trigger an
exception except x equals 4 4 plus 4 and
then finally print do something else
with X which equals and then we'll just
you know spit out the value of x so
track set finally so now let's go ahead
and save that run that and we get do
something else with X which equals 8 now
obviously if we change this to 3 and we
rerun this it's gonna say do something
else with X which equals 6 so finally is
always gonna run and at least in this
case it's gonna use 6 for the value of x
but obviously if the exception was
called it would say we'd be using 8 of
course but that's not all for 3 easy
payments of $29.99 so to do that let's
do a quick example
you're gonna stuff the else statement
right here and we're gonna say else X
plus equals 1 so again how does the else
statement work it works when the
exception is not triggered it's as if
except is if so in this scenario since X
is the try is legitimate X is defined a
6 it's going to not trigger the accept
therefore the else will run so it's
going to add 1 so it's going to spit out
X is 7 right so well it wouldn't spit
anything out at this point but X will be
7 then finally
is always gonna run so it's gonna
actually print out X do something with X
which equals now what is equal equals
seven so now let's go ahead and run that
maybe and we see do something else with
X which equals seven now again if we say
this X right so now try is gonna fail
except we'll run because except runs
else will not run so X is going to equal
8 finally always runs so it's gonna run
and then it's gonna say I do something
else with X which equals and it's gonna
be 8 so again let's run this and sure
enough as we expected do something else
with X which equals 8 so does both you
know try except finally but also try
cept else finally so anyways hopefully
you guys enjoy it hopefully you guys
maybe learn something new if you have
any questions feel free to put them in
the comments below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support in
the subscriptions and until next time